hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the London
chess Classic this is a game from round
three and a couple of very nice games
have been played I will feature them all
uh but this is the one I'm starting with
and for a very good reason you will see
why uh so it's GES versus two times
Ukrainian Champion Andre volokitin who
also represented Ukraine four times in
the Olympics and even won Gold for his
team in
2004 uh so definitely strong player uh
and interestingly gkes lost a lot of
rating points in no M he was uh already
in the top 10 but now he's back to
2720 uh so uh it's very hard to say will
he be able to play as as many games as
necessary to get his rating up to to
maybe even qualify for the candidat
tournament he is definitely strong
enough to do it uh we we'll see what
happens so let's check it out gukesh has
the white pieces and he opens with Pawn
to C4 he goes for the English opening
Knight to F6 by Andre we have Knight to
C3 and pawn to C5 going going
symmetrical we have Pawn to G3 and pawn
to D5 offering a trade in the center
which Gish goes for Knight captures Pawn
captures Knight captures and Bishop to
G2 now putting pressure on the Knight
and sometimes the Knight on C3 is
captured but mostly Knight to C7 is the
main move considered best nice to
unnecessarily trade down we have Pawn to
B3 Gish now ready to F get to his other
Bishop as well we have Pawn to E5 and
Bishop to B2 we have Bishop to E7 Andre
ready to Castle and to Rook to C1
getting ready to put pressure on that C5
Pawn whether by playing Knight to A4 or
maybe some other moves we have castles
uh and now uh no moves here are just the
continuing development with Knight H3
also Knight to A4 going after the C5
Pawn but gush plays Knight to E4 and it
is now already as of move nine that we
have a completely new game and how can
black react to this okay your C5 Pawn is
hanging you could just defend it with
Pawn to B6 that that's what was uh
played in the game uh you could maybe
ignore it play Knight to D7 uh but also
defend the pawn this way but you could
also ignore it by playing Knight to C6 I
will show it because it's a super fun
line where black sacrifices two pawns uh
for uh for a beautiful initiative now
the idea is that after Knight captures
you will play Knight to E6 you offer a
trade of knights and after captures
captures you allow uh the E5 Pawn to be
captured as well Bishop captures Pawn
captures and now Bishop captures on E5
uh does U uh leave you with five points
against but you do have the bishop pair
for example you can play Bishop A3 you
go after the Rook here now of course
capturing would be too dangerous due to
Bishop to D5 and then attack on both
Rooks and if you go something like Rook
to C3 then you can play Rook to E8 put
some pressure on the bishop here and if
Knight to F3 defending the bishop and
preparing to Castle you can play Bishop
D5 so it's uh sort of scary you can't
Castle because of Bishop captur removing
the defender of E5 bishop and it's a
it's a very active play now with perfect
play of course white will
uh handle this properly give back uh at
least one pawn and okay uh the game uh
should be equal uh but you know it's if
you want to play that way uh but after
Knight to E4 Andre decided to go for
Pawn to B6 he gave up the E5 Pawn also
for some very active counterplay Bishop
captures an E5 and now Bishop to B7 so
okay you have to do something Bishop
back to A1 you don't want the bishop to
be a Target here and now comes Queen to
C8 this is a very nice move as it
prevents any sort of Knight Q F6 check
action followed by picking up the bishop
and The Rook Here and Now Andre is
asking lukish what is your next move
because it's very hard to develop here
you can just go Knight F3 because the
Knight hangs here if if you move the
Knight then the bishop on G2 hangs you
cannot even develop with Knight to H3
because simply Bishop captures uh or not
just that you can even play F5 uh and
then uh capture the bishop here so not
uh not a lot of fun after this queen to
C8 move so what does gcash do uh he
plays Pawn to G4 and the idea is that
now you don't have to you don't have to
worry about any sneaky tricks because uh
uh the the the queen also does not have
access to H3 so that's also one of the
reasons for example if the Knight comes
to H3 you can even play Bishop captures
on e4 that's the idea and if Bishop
captures Queen captures on H3 and now if
you play Bishop captures on a the Knight
covers the A8 square and black is of
course now completely winning but with
the inclusion of this G four move uh the
queen does not have access to uh to H3
in that line that we've just shown so
what can you do here capturing not the
best because you leave the bishop
unattended so now Knight to F6 check
will again cost you this uh bishop and
The Rook here so what can you do after
Queen to C8 and G4 best is to continue
Knight to C6 but Andre went for Knight
to E6 and this is where things get very
interesting now Gish gets to develop
Knight H3 Knight to C6 and now Pawn to
E3 okay not all all that clear what Gish
is doing but you will see very quickly
Knight to B4 goes after the A2 pawn and
Gish says all right you can you can have
that pawn Knight captures on A2 and now
as The Rook is attacked Rook to B1
Knight back to B4 and now Pawn to F4 and
all of a sudden uh gkes has a castled
king and he has a beautiful attacking
setup with F5 and G5 being ready to be
pushed the Knight is already very close
to the black king this night as well the
bishop on this diagonal absolute Beast
uh so this is what Gish got for his
tricky play so Pawn to F6 uh limits the
power of the of the bishop on A1 now
usually you don't want to play this move
but here it's actually the strongest
move recommended by the engine Queen to
F3 sort of putting the queen in front of
the bishop but you are not planning to
leave it there for long Bishop to C6 and
now the bishop to C6 comes so it adds
more defense to it but also you want to
shift the queen to B7 to add more
pressure to this diagonal uh now comes
Pawn to F5 and this is the tricky moment
in the game where uh where Andre has to
decide what to do with the Knight and
the only good move is Knight to G5 which
he did not go for I'm going to show it
to you because it's a it's a beautiful
capture Fest that ends up with a sort of
a drawn position and Knight captures on
H5 F captures on G5 Queen to G3 now
unpinning from the bishop here now Queen
to B8 offering a queen trade Bishop to
B5 stop Bishop D5 stopping it Queen to
B7 and now Pawn to F6 and after G
captures you will play Knight captures
on F6 Bishop captures Bishop captures
and after Bishop captures on G2 you will
have to trade Queens Queen captures on
G2 Queen captures on G2 King captures
and now Pawn to H6 you will defend your
Pawn here equal material H should be an
equal game uh but in the game after F5
he did not go for Knight to G5 Andre
went for Knight to C7 and now gkes has a
beautiful attack starting with Pawn to
G5 so what do you do here uh you could
uh try some uh some developing moves but
uh uh d f captures and G5 was played and
now the idea is Queen to G3 putting more
pressure on G5 so Pawn to H6 and now
Pawn to F6 blasting through G captures
on F6 and now uh what you capture with
of course you capture with our good
friend the bishop I know you guys forgot
about him but he's still here Bishop
captures on F6 and now Bishop captures
on e4 and we reached the position from
the thumbnail where only one move uh
gives Gish a clear winning Advantage so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find an absolute best move out of this
complete mess of a position while I give
you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
playing something weird like Bishop
captures and G5 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Knight
captures and G5 that's the move that
solves the position and the reason is
you take away all of the squares from
the the black king the king cannot move
and you cannot get out of this uh nasty
position so what can you do if you
capture the Knight you're just getting
checkmated Queen captures on G5 King F7
and now it's a matter of a few moves
King E7 Queen captures here and after
King to D5 Bishop captures on e4 any
move really will get the black king
checkmated So after this Knight captures
on G5 move you cannot move the king you
cannot capture the Knight you might as
well take something Bishop captures on
F6 was played by Andre H but now Rook
captures on F6 and again capturing on G5
is not an option even though you removed
one of the Defenders because now after
you capture King to h8 now Rook H6 check
Bishop to H7 seems like black was able
to defend but Rook captures on H7 opens
up this diagonal for the light Square
bishop and that's pretty much it Bishop
E4 check King h8 and now you get
checkmated so after Rook captures on F6
Rook captures on F6 was played and now
Knight captures on e4 with check nicely
connecting here and it doesn't matter if
the black king defends The Rook or not
if you defend the Rook you can simply
capture here and after King captures the
other Rook gets the job done the queen
Rook Bishop combo will be deadly let's
say King E7 Queen to H4 check King to D6
you can bring a rook into the game with
check King D7 Rook to F7 again with
check King to D6 and now Queen to E7
Checkmate or any of the possible lines
that also result in Checkmate so King to
h8 was played and here just Knight
captures on F6 leaving black or rather
leaving Andre with an equal material but
his position is uh just unplayable uh
there there's really nothing for you to
try H he tried Queen to F5 sort of going
after the rook and the Knight but it
doesn't matter gcas just played Rook to
F1 and he was in this position un move
28 that Andre voltin resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
his Queen is hanging also now his Rooks
and Knight are hard defended Gish Rooks
and rook and Knight are defended and the
Knight on C7 will hang there is no
square for the for the black queen where
you can defend that knight uh okay maybe
you can go to for Queen to C8 but now
Queen to G6 goes after Checkmate here
and uh there's no way to stop it if if
you play Queen f8 then Queen to H7 is
Checkmate uh if you go Queen to G8 to
stop this well obviously you can capture
but also just Queen captures and H6 is
Checkmate so there is no move you can H
make the stop Checkmate here so after
Rook to F1 he resigned and a very nice
victory for gkes uh who won his first
game but then was a very close to losing
against Nikita viigo there was that one
move in the end game where Vito could
have sort of played it a bit more slower
and prepare and he would have gotten a
winning position but uh I mean you you
have to play Perfect move so he was able
to survive that he got a draw and now a
wonderful win against Andre voltin uh
leaves gkes in the lead after three
rounds have been played of the London
chess classic or rather it's it's a
joint lead uh with Michael Adams who's
also uh playing some incredible chess so
we're going to uh cover some other games
as well after this one uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it
brilliant brilliant played by gkes that
G4 move I mean you you really can't make
this stuff up it was um uh G4 here just
getting out of this position I mean if
you don't know this I I imagine it was
prepared but in case it wasn't just
absolute brilliancy by by Gish but even
if it was prepared I mean w wow uh so
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank David
gasparian Dan Schwarz keep up the rapid
Robert andalan sigon willson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day